>> Di chúc: Dòng một,
James, chúng ta đang làm gì vậy? >> James: Bạn đang tuyên bố
một chức năng được gọi là PrintHello >> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
công việc tốt từ James.
Dòng hai, tôi chưa gọi cho ai?
Tôi đã kêu gọi hầu hết mọi người bây giờ. >> Will Sentance: Tôi đã kêu gọi mọi
người độc thân, Mike, dòng hai, chúng ta đang làm gì?
>> Mike: Khối chức năng cho
một giây được khai báo. >> Will Sentance: Chặn trong một giây.
Và vì chúng tôi không chỉ định cách nó hoạt động nhất thiết, nhưng chức năng này,
khi nó được gọi, sẽ ở trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi trong 1.000 mili giây.
Đây không phải là một chức năng gửi công việc ra nền.
Nó sẽ ở đó trong 1.000 mili giây.
Sonia bạn có thể nghĩ ra cách mà tôi có thể viết các hàm như
rằng tôi đã làm điều đó?
Tôi có thể làm gì mà sẽ mất 1.000 mili giây?
Nó phải nằm trong chuỗi công việc,
nó sẽ làm một cái gì đó rất nhanh.
Các tác vụ nhỏ, rất nhanh.
Ben, bạn có thể nghĩ gì? >> Ben: Vòng lặp.
>> Will Sentance: Looping, chính xác là
lặp lại sẽ làm điều đó.
Rất nhiều bước xử lý nhỏ rất, rất nhanh.
Nó sẽ là một vòng lặp lớn để
1000 mili giây kéo dài trong một công cụ JavaScript hiện đại.
Vòng lặp cũ lớn.
Nhưng có một vòng lặp đủ dài sẽ kéo dài 1000 mili giây.
Bạn không làm điều đó bên ngoài JavaScript.
Đó là rất nhiều JavaScript thuần túy.
Và do đó đang chặn chúng tôi tiếp tục trong mã của mình khi hàm đó được gọi cho
1000 mili giây.
Thông minh.
Bây giờ, bây giờ Mike, chúng tôi sẽ gọi
setTimeout với đối số, in chào
định nghĩa hàm chắc chắn chúng ta không gọi nó và đối số 0.
Vì vậy, Mike cố gắng nói với tôi về những gì sẽ xảy ra ở đây,
và nó sẽ là về các tính năng của trình duyệt web của chúng tôi phải không.
Vậy điều gì sẽ xảy ra ở đây Mike? >> Mike: Tôi không chắc.
Tôi chỉ biết nó không phải. >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy
setTimeout được thiết lập là gì. >> Ben: Nó sẽ
thiết lập bối cảnh thực thi cục bộ. >> Will Sentance: Có phải không?
>> Ben: Không, nó sẽ gọi là mặt tiền
chức năng. >> Will Sentance: Ha.
SetTimeout không,
nó làm được gì trong JavaScript? >> Ben: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Nó không có gì trong
JavaScript.
Thay vào đó, nó sẽ, nó là một nhãn,
nó là một chức năng mặt tiền cho một tính năng của trình duyệt web.
Tính năng nào vậy Ben? >> Ben: Hẹn giờ.
>> Will Sentance: Hẹn giờ, vì vậy
nó sẽ tạo ra một tính năng của trình duyệt web,
tính năng hẹn giờ.
Và nó sẽ thực hiện hai điều quan trọng mà nó cần biết.
Và trong trình duyệt web, bao nhiêu mili giây, Mike,
bộ hẹn giờ này sẽ chạy trong khoảng thời gian nào? >> Mike: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Zero mili giây và tương tự
nói một phần nghìn giây, đó là khi chúng ta
bắt đầu, bộ hẹn giờ này đã hoàn thành chưa?
Mike?
Nó hoàn thành ngay lập tức.
Chính xác.
Và sau khi hoàn thành, chúng ta muốn làm gì?
Chúng tôi muốn gọi in xin chào.
Chúng tôi muốn chuyển nó trở lại thành JavaScript hoặc tham chiếu nó trong JavaScript và
bắt đầu chạy bằng JavaScript. >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy
print hello ngay lập tức sẵn sàng chạy, vì vậy
chúng ta có thêm nó thẳng vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi không? >> tắt màn hình: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Tại sao không?
>> tắt màn hình: Đó là
sự ngăn chặn. >> Di chúc: Không.
Nhưng nó đã sẵn sàng ở đây.
Nó đã sẵn sàng để hoạt động trở lại. >> tắt màn hình: Bởi vì bạn không ở trong
JavaScript bối cảnh hoặc trong thế giới của trình duyệt. >> Will Sentance: Nhưng chúng tôi.
Chúng ta đang quay lại với ngữ cảnh JavaScript.
Nhìn. Dòng tiếp theo là hai mili giây.
Sao anh này không nhìn lại được.
Chúng tôi đã nói bất cứ khi nào nó sẵn sàng, hãy quay lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Vâng, bạn nói đúng.
Dòng mã tiếp theo mà chúng ta sẽ đạt được ở tốc độ 2 mili giây là khối 41 giây.
Chúng tôi không chắc nó sẽ hoạt động như thế nào nhưng chúng tôi biết khi chúng tôi đi sâu vào nó,
chúng ta sẽ dành bao nhiêu mili giây bên trong nó,
Josh? >> Josh: Mili giây?
1000. >> Will Sentance: 1000, tốt.
Nhân tiện, Josh đã thực hiện rất tốt điều chỉnh từ giây đến mili giây của anh ấy.
Chính xác, cộng thêm 1000 mili giây.
Điều đó sẽ nằm trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi, vì vậy chúng tôi có toàn cầu ở phía dưới,
chặn trong một giây >> Will Sentance: Sẽ ngồi trên
gọi ngăn xếp trong 1000 mili giây.
Có thể trong thời gian đó, bản in hello đã sẵn sàng hoạt động.
Có thể trong lúc đó, nó nhảy lên trên và bắt đầu chạy.
Nó có làm được điều đó không?
Đó sẽ là một ngôn ngữ khủng khiếp. >> [ĐỦ]
>> Will Sentance: Có thể có.
Tôi có nghĩa là nó chắc chắn có thể.
Nhưng điều đó sẽ rất tùy ý, rất tùy ý về thời điểm mã của chúng ta thực thi.
Vì vậy, nó chắc chắn không thể làm, như Michelle đã nói, nó chắc chắn không thể
chuyển print hello trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi trong khi thực thi một hàm khác.
Điều đó trông khá rõ ràng.
Nó thuộc loại ngẫu nhiên tùy ý.
Nhưng có thể khi hàm đó thực thi xong,
khi hàm đó thực thi xong và chúng tôi nhận được khối cho
một giây ra khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi và chúng tôi trả lại chuỗi của chúng tôi
ở tốc độ 1002 mili giây, có thể giờ đây việc in hello được cho phép trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Ai nghĩ rằng nó được phép trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi?
Tôi đang làm câu trả lời của tôi là không có giọng nói.
Ai nghĩ nó được phép
trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi? >> Alec: Có thể.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, Alec, có thể,
>> [ĐỦ]
>> Will Sentance: Thật không may, không.
Mặc dù xin chào bằng chữ in nhỏ nghèo nàn, nó vẫn đang ngồi đó.
Tôi đã sẵn sàng chạy, chạy tôi, sẵn sàng chạy, vào lúc này,
1.001 mili giây kể từ khi nó được khởi chạy lần đầu tiên.
Bộ hẹn giờ đã khởi động, nó hoàn tất ngay lập tức,
print hello ngay lập tức sẵn sàng hoạt động trở lại, nhưng nó không được phép bật lại.
Chúng tôi sẽ thấy quy tắc chính xác tại sao, thực sự chúng tôi sẽ truy cập nhật ký bảng điều khiển tiếp theo.
Tôi, chúc tôi già trước.
Nếu nó nói với tôi trước tiên, bạn biết nó sẽ giao diện điều khiển ghi lại nó trước.
Đây rồi, tôi trước.
Ở 1002 mili giây. >> Will Sentance: Được rồi.
Bây giờ chúng ta có nghĩ đến thời điểm này khi chúng ta đã hoàn thành tất cả mã toàn cầu của mình,
chúng tôi nghĩ bây giờ in lời chào được cho phép trở lại?
In Xin chào bây giờ đã được cho phép trở lại.
Nhưng làm thế nào để nó hoạt động trở lại?
Hóa ra là chúng ta cần thêm hai mảnh ghép nữa.
Chúng ta cần một quy tắc cơ bản.
Quy tắc cơ bản của chúng tôi về thời điểm chức năng bị trì hoãn.
Bây giờ có, nó chỉ bị trì hoãn bởi 0 mili giây.
Nhưng nó vẫn bị loại bỏ khỏi JavaScript và được liên kết với trình duyệt web.
Nó đã bị loại bỏ khỏi JavaScript.
Chúng tôi cần một quy tắc về thời điểm cho phép thứ bị loại bỏ khỏi JavaScript
trở lại JavaScript.
Và chúng tôi có một quy tắc đơn giản,
Tôi phải hoàn thành việc làm trống ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của mình về bất kỳ chức năng nào sẽ được chạy,
và hoàn tất việc chạy tất cả mã đồng bộ toàn cầu, tất cả các mã của tôi.
Tôi có thể có 1000 nhật ký bảng điều khiển.
Loại điên rồ.
Tôi có thể đã chia nhỏ chức năng khác nhau này bên trong một lệnh gọi hàm,
ra khỏi nó.
Có 1000 cuộc gọi, tôi có thể có một vòng lặp trong khi vô hạn với các lần đăng nhập bảng điều khiển.
Và tôi sẽ không bao giờ cho phép in lời chào trở lại trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Nó không bao giờ được phép trở lại.
Tại sao?
Vì khi tôi hoàn thành các tính năng nền hoạt động,
in hello không đi thẳng vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Như Brian đã gợi ý, nó chuyển sang một thứ gọi là hàng đợi.
Tôi đoán nó được xếp hàng đợi như một cuộc gọi lại.
Điều này có một vài tên, hàng đợi nhiệm vụ.
Chúng ta có thể gọi nó là hàng đợi nhiệm vụ macro vào lúc này không?
Nhưng hàng đợi gọi lại là hàng đợi các hàm
sẵn sàng xuất hiện trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Đó là bản in xin chào, Blessing, xấp xỉ mili giây
in lời chào đã thêm vào hàng đợi gọi lại? >> Phước lành: Một phần nghìn giây.
>> Di chúc: Vào khoảng một
chính xác là mili giây, đó là một mili giây và sau đó chúng ta có quy tắc của mình.
Khi nào thì chức năng này được phép quay trở lại JavaScript?
Nó chỉ được phép trở lại JavaScript khi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi trống và
tất cả mã toàn cầu của chúng tôi đã chạy xong.
Và quy tắc đó, hoặc việc kiểm tra quy tắc đó, có một tên sang trọng.
Đó là một loại quá trình nhỏ, đó là một quá trình ẩn dụ.
Toàn bộ quá trình được lặp lại và kiểm tra rất nhanh.
Tất nhiên là AMD?
Tất cả mã toàn cầu đã chạy xong chưa?
Hàng đợi có gì trong đó không?
Tất nhiên là AMD?
Hàng đợi có gì không?
Và đó được gọi là vòng lặp sự kiện.
Công việc là phải nói rằng liệu trình AMD đã hoàn thành việc chạy tất cả những thứ của nó?
Mã toàn cầu đã được thực thi xong chưa?
Có phải một cái gì đó trong cốt lõi?
Có, có!
Điều này không trống trong một thời gian dài, tại thời điểm này, vòng lặp sự kiện sẽ không, không, không,
chúng tôi không thể thêm bất cứ thứ gì vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi vì nó đã bị chặn trong một giây.
Nhưng ngay cả khi đó, nhật ký giao diện điều khiển vẫn đang ở đó cần được chạy.
Nó đã sẵn sàng để chạy trong bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu.
Ha, tại thời điểm này sự kiện đi là ghế trống?
Vâng, đúng vậy.
Cuộc gọi lại ở đây có một cái gì đó trong đó nên hãy in xin chào,
bạn cuối cùng là 1001 mili giây sau khi bạn bị hoãn 0 mili giây,
cuối cùng bạn cũng được phép trở lại
ngăn xếp cuộc gọi ở 1003 mili giây.
Và lưu ý những thời gian này là thứ tự.
Chúng không phải, chúng theo thứ tự, ngoài những thứ chính yếu,
Được chứ. >> Will Sentance: Ý nghĩa thông thường là
về thứ tự của chúng, ở 1003 mili giây.
Cuối cùng, in lời chào được cho phép trở lại ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi,
ở 1003 mili giây, chúng tôi in lời chào, đó là mọi người.
Một quy trình tuyệt vời để trì hoãn chức năng của chúng tôi, sau đó chỉ được phép
quay lại JavaScript trong một điều kiện nhất định, điều kiện đó được kiểm tra
bởi vòng lặp sự kiện này đang kiểm tra nó lặp lại rất nhanh, mang tính ẩn dụ nhưng
nó đang lặp lại rất nhanh để kiểm tra điều kiện này.
Là hàng đợi gọi lại, nó có một cái gì đó trong đó?
Nó cho phép nó hoạt động trở lại khi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi hoàn toàn trống và
ngữ cảnh thực thi toàn cầu của chúng tôi đã chạy xong tất cả mã của nó.
Và đó là nó.
Sáu phần này là cốt lõi của mô hình JavaScript không đồng bộ của chúng tôi.
Giải pháp ba sẽ cho chúng ta thấy rằng JavaScript gần đây đã giới thiệu hai
các bộ phận bổ sung cho mô hình này.
Chúng ta sẽ xem chúng trong giải pháp ba.
Nhưng hiện tại, không thích sáu phần cốt lõi này, bộ nhớ,
luồng thực thi, ngăn xếp cuộc gọi đại diện cho ngữ cảnh thực thi của chúng tôi,
các tính năng của trình duyệt web của chúng tôi, hàng đợi gọi lại của chúng tôi khi tính năng trình duyệt web của chúng tôi
kết thúc công việc của nó là nơi hàm của chúng ta sẽ được gửi đi.
Điều đó đã được trì hoãn bởi chức năng mặt tiền của chúng tôi
quay bộ đếm thời gian tính năng của trình duyệt web đó.
Và cuối cùng, vòng lặp sự kiện của chúng tôi sẽ kiểm tra hàng đợi gọi lại đó.
Nó nói có cái gì đó trong đó?
Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng ta có tốt và trống không và không có mã chung nào để chạy?
Và nói rằng không sao, bạn được phép trở lại.